all right welcome my name is Dan Galpin
and we're gonna be talking about garbage
today I hope everyone is really excited
to hear about garbage a little bit about
me I have spent the last over five years
as a developer advocate on the Android
team mostly working with game developers
which is why I end up dealing with so
many low-level things but also doing a
couple of fun things you might have have
seen I'm really proud of the work we've
done with Udacity I worked on both the
Android fundamentals class introduction
to Android as well as the advanced
Android class and I have had no sleep
literally I have not slept at about two
days so this should be exciting and yeah
and I think I'm funny so um so I had a
confession to make if you looked at the
description of this talk when Ian me
Lewis who noticed is not here and I
started planning this talk we were
thinking like ocean liner big and we
wanted to cover all sorts of things we
wanted to cover binder and art in the
oat format you know services whose
name's end in flinger you name it but a
few weeks ago we realized two things
first there was no way we had time for
all that even though we could write a
talk that would cover all of that we
still couldn't deliver it in 40 minutes
secondly there are ease a series of
books and talks called Android internals
that covered lots of what we were
planning so we decided to focus the talk
so instead I want to talk about one of
the journeys that we've taken through
the internals of Android I should also
mention that I did not write large
chunks of this talk Ian E Lewis my
cohort did but he couldn't be here today
I am however responsible for all of the
slides
he wrote a script that I'm going to read
word for word because I will forever
stand in utter awe of his technical
brilliance and because I haven't slept
in about a week so let's get started the
great thing about spelunking through the
bowels of Android is that pretty much
anyone can do it it's the beauty of open
source and you might think that since I
worked for Google I have some kind of
special advantage when it comes to
understanding Android I mean anytime I
want to I can walk over and talk
directly it's one of the amazing people
that actually wrote the system and it is
pretty awesome but not only do I try to
avoid doing that more than I have to the
knowledge is actually pretty much spread
out over lots of people these days so
while the Android engineering team is
amazing and I'm honestly really
fortunate to be working with them what I
really want to know how something works
I'll at least first get into some code
and try to find out for myself so today
I'm going to tell you a story about a an
and I journey deep into the Android
runtime and found out something for
ourselves specifically it's a story of
how we found out why you have to be
careful not to waste too much time when
trying to avoid allocations especially
when you're running on art and we're
actually gonna show you how we did it
this particular story begins with a deck
of cards
which is exceptionally appropriate since
it also ends with cards now ian was
writing a demo that true playing cards
it was supposed to be an experiment
about overdraw but that actually turned
out to be the least interesting part of
the demo now card games are a great test
for overdraw because stacks of them have
a lot of overlapping objects but none of
them are transparent like these ones are
so there's a huge difference between the
number of pixels you draw in the worst
case which is the number you draw in the
best case but to get that best case
performance you have to figure out
exactly which parts of the card are
visible now there's a general algorithm
for doing that but requires a lot of
bookkeeping because it involves
splitting rectangles into some unknown
number of smaller rectangles now the
thing you need to understand about Ian
who was doing this is that he is a C++
programmer more than that he's a game
programmer a game written in C++ this
problem would be the perfect candidate
for some kind of object pool so he
decided to keep all of the rectangles in
a simple pool now how many people out
there have actually used simple pool in
their coding it's part of the support
library I don't think he expected the
object pool to make a huge performance
difference but he thought it might help
a little what surprised us both was that
it didn't help at all
instead it totally tanked I mean the
performance was absolutely abysmal and
so we just
look for answers we started where most
people start when they have a
performance problem with the sampling
method profiler and traceview how many
of you have used Tracy you out there
come a show of hands oh that's good
you're listening that's awesome
the profiler isn't as good as this trace
at catching intermittent performance
spikes but it's really great at getting
a big-picture view of what's expensive
and what isn't and here we are the
culprit is simple pool release now
here's what that code looks like that is
in pool line looks kind of suspicious
sounds like it might be a linear search
and of course we look back at our trace
you output we also see that is in pool
there's right at the top of our list so
clearly it's costly and it actually does
do a linear search it goes to check
everything in the array to see if it's
already in the pool so you have a really
big pool it's actually really expensive
especially since array access is not
particularly cheap so we decided to make
it even simpler pool well that was easy
we'll just make our own pool with a
Cabana waterfall a diving board I mean
with unchecked releases very easy to get
those mixed up we're living on the edge
and of course traits you output looks
like this it fixes our performance
problems yes it turns out you should be
really careful when using simple pool
that linear search really makes large
pools slow we could pack up and go home
now but now we've got some code to play
with so we decided to find out how big
of a deal is allocation in our anyway I
mean we did some crazy tests like
allocating thousands and thousands of
objects in ondraw and we found that in
most cases unless the object was really
expensive to create like a paint object
it didn't really affect our frame rate
and we're like I mean no we didn't just
suddenly find out that allocations were
free all that stuff Colt McAnlis told
you is still true what this experience
taught us was that we didn't understand
how allocations affected performance
quite as well as we thought we did and
when you start seeing performance
numbers that you don't expect that's a
perfect time to start digging into the
code so off to the debugger I know
you're thinking I love reading through
code as much as the next crazy person
but sometimes you just got to step
through it to understand it now there's
a lot of ways to debug the Android
runtime
some are easy and some are hard and
let's make things easy on
ourselves first and this is gonna shock
you we're actually gonna debug an
emulator build okay now how many of you
actually use the emulator when you're
when you're writing Android software
okay well so devices are kind of finicky
so our network connections and USB
cables we're actually gonna be doing a
lot of native debugging and unless
you're trying to you know debug an issue
with hardware code generation there's
really not a big difference these days
between debugging against the emulator
and a real device in addition when
you're running on the emulator you get
to run as root and our images also
include a version of gdb server so
you've got super super reliable
debugging believe it or not if you need
to do native debugging on Android second
we get to avoid using ADB which is
really cool why because ADB was designed
to be cheap slow and reliable and if
really manages to achieve two of those
goals
now ADB is okay if you're using the gdb
command-line you know which I know some
of you are totally into so if you're one
of those people just go back to your
Emacs or whatever for a minute or two
while I talk to everyone else when I'm
stepping through unknown code I really
prefer to use some kind of GUI now the
ian is a huge fan of QT creator because
it's free and because it's not eclipse
but adb can't handle the amount of gdb
traffic that an idea like that generates
it works for a while but at some point
it just decides to quit but fortunately
the emulator has its own IP port
redirector that doesn't rely on adb and
my experience with that is that it's
really really solid third download the
AOSP codebase and build your own
emulator image now you don't have to do
this but it's so totally worth it for
one thing you don't have to worry about
your sources symbols and binaries being
in sync for another thing and this is
really important for this particular
quest you can actually disable
optimizations on modules you want to
debug which make make stepping through
the code a lot easier now once you have
a rock-solid debugger attached to the
runtime it's kind of addictive I mean
you're seeing Android from a completely
new angle it's like you've been poking
around a cave with
candle and someone just gave you this
high-powered flashlight and if you're
running a Windows box building Android
is a good excuse to install Linux VM
alright let's start with my favorite
piece of code the bytecode interpreter
now there are actually two different
implementations depending on how you
compile it one is a go to table
implementation which is one of those
pieces of code that simultaneously
proves why C macros are horrible and why
they're never going to go away but
fortunately if you set the right
compiler options you get the
implementation in interpreter switch
imple dot c c which looks exactly like
you always thought it would just one
giant switch statement with a case for
each opcode if you've been struggling to
figure out what's going on in the
interpreter just sing this enough is to
make you cry it doesn't see as much
traffic as it used to because of all the
head ahead of time compiling but if you
turn that off this piece of code becomes
the leeks cafe a Mac kind of switch
statements everybody comes here which
makes it the perfect place to set some
breakpoints and learn how the runtime
works now since we're trying to minimize
our allocation costs maybe we should
start by looking at how object
allocation actually happens now all
object allocation starts at the same
place in this interpreter which is this
new instance dalvik opcode but as soon
as we get into the implementation of
that object so it turns out that the art
memory system is massively polymorphic
there are actually eight different kinds
of allocators that might be returned
from get current allocator
now this is one of those points where
it's really great to be stepping through
in the debugger instead of just reading
the code because we can see exactly what
we're getting which is Ra's alack I mean
not always but usually and Roz stands
for run of slots which is basically a
fancy-pants way of saying fixed sized
block allocator the slot is a fixed size
block the run is an array of those
blocks and the allocator owns a set of
runs now each rod has a different slot
size to a connote hold
objective that size or smaller and
unlike my diagram the number of slots in
each run is actually calculated to make
the run and as close to a page boundary
as possible now this is an awesome
allocator it's not the most efficient as
far as memory usage but it's got two
really nice advantages one is that it's
practically immune to fragmentation
second bookkeeping is really easy you
never need to split or coalesce blocks
and you don't need to store the size of
each allocation because the address of
the allocation tells you everything you
need to know so even though you waste a
little space the end of any object
that's not exactly the size of its slot
its slot you get some of that back
without by not having to store any extra
cruft alongside it in the heap so not to
mention that it avoids date alignment
problems if you happen to have any of
those there's one really interesting way
that Roz alec is different from the
alligators you see in things like game
programming because game programmers
tend to use a stack to keep track of
free elements now you can implement that
in a little array of bytes or shorts
that has the same number of elements as
there are slots in the run and it lets
you do both allocations and
deallocations in constant time Roz alec
on the other hand treats tracks free
slots in a bitmap to allocate you
actually have to look through the bitmap
TIFF until you find a zero now
technically that's an O n operation and
when I first look at this I thought it
was kind of weird
and I thought it was kind of interesting
and then I realized it was freaking
brilliant okay
and here's why first off yes the
allocation is order n but remember these
are actually fairly small little groups
you're allocating from so it's n times a
very small constant furthermore most
CPUs can find the first cleared bit in a
word on a single instruction so the
worst cake waste the first taste
allocation cost is just the number of
slots divided by the number of bits in a
machine work on Android we actually
negate the bitmap board and then use
something called underscore built-in
underscore ffs to find the index of the
first non set bit so we actually use a
compiler intrinsic for that and that's
not even the brilliant part though
because the brilliant part is what
happens on D allocation because
allocation in a multi-threaded
environment is a huge pain
the best way to make it fast is to
remove the concurrency just give each
thread its own separate allocator make
that and make a rule that memory has to
be freed on the same thread that
allocated it but that really sucks for
garbage collection because part of the
appeal is that you can do a lot of the
work on a background thread after all we
all have multi-core systems we tend to
have a core free that's not doing a lot
and what you get with roz alec is almost
the best of both worlds see there's
actually multiple bitmaps for every run
one tracks which slots are in use like I
talked about earlier but another one
tracks slots that have been freed by a
different thread so instead of
synchronizing the free list on every
deallocation you can wait until it's
convenient and apply all pending the
allocations by just Nanding the two
bitmaps
by the way I'm showing a lot of source
code here and it's a little small so I
apologize in the middle of this once
again though this is frakking brilliant
because you can now have n yes you can
have thread local runs and locks are
started by slot size so that even shared
runs have way lower contention there's a
bunch of other cool stuff in rows Alec
but we should probably move on before
everyone too starts calling me the crazy
rows Alec guy so the really sad thing is
it's hard to implement well you really
can't effluent anything that's elegant
in Java you'd end up reinventing the
entire reference system and if you get
kind of a maintenance nightmare so yeah
allocating from our object pool as a
whole isn't a whole lot faster than
allocating from the normal Java heap and
it's way more work but we kind of
expected that I mean no one ever
explains about the cost of allocation in
a garbage collected runtime it's always
about the cost of collection so the
question is why aren't we seeing these
massive collection pauses when we
allocated massive numbers of short-lived
objects now rog Alec gave us a little
bit of a clue they didn't spend all that
effort on concurrency for nothing it's
not that the garbage collector is doing
nothing it's that a lot of its work is
being done somewhere else other than the
main thread and it still work and we'd
like to minimize it but it's not call it
causing the jank that it did on dalvik
so there's one piece left in this puzzle
and it has to do with how the Jie
see manages to do so much of its work on
a background thread now actually since
we spent so much time talking about how
great the allocator is at concurrency
it's probably worth going over why this
is even a problem now the GC has to
figure out which objects are live and
which are dead and it does this by
starting with the object on the stack
and following their references all the
way down till there are no more
references left to follow every object
that cut visited during that procedure
must be live because clearly there's a
chain of references that your
application could follow to access that
object every object that get left out is
dead or at least it's not live now the
GC guys tell me that's a little bit of
an oversimplification but it's a good
first approximation thing is this
process is not lightning-fast and if
it's done concurrently then your
application is busy connecting and
disconnecting and reconnecting
references while the GC is trying to
trace them so let's say that object egg
has a reference to object B an object C
has a reference type that's currently
null now for whatever reason the GC
visits object C before it visits object
a following me okay now let's say that
after the GC has visited C but before it
visits a you give object bead object C
and no lattes reference for all the GC
can tell a and C both have a null
reference and it never even saw B so the
question is how do you fix this and it
turns out the answer to that question
tells us a lot about how we can shoot
ourselves in the foot by trying to
outsmart the garbage collector and it
takes us back to the subject of cards if
you take another look at the glorious
switch statement that is at the heart of
the dalvik interpreter you'll notice
that a lot of op codes have an extra
call on them then this call to check
suspend is a check point it's a place
where the thread checks to see if the GC
wants it to do anything among other
things this check lets the GC tell the
thread to stop completely which is what
it has to do if it wants to get an
accurate count of which objects are dead
and which ones are alive this is called
the GC pause now
clearly one way to make sure the GC gets
an accurate count is just to visit the
objects all over again but that would be
a colossal waste of time I mean that
would be like a cupcake move so instead
how about how we just revisit the
objects that got changed while we were
busy doing our first pass on the object
graph now you're talking that's some
gingerbread level thinking my friends so
how do we tell what's changed let's go
back to that switch statement one last
time now you probably haven't notices
but there's actually a specific set of
op codes just removing references and
you know that might strike you as being
odd because references are just for byte
binary values - same as integers you
know why not just reuse the existing
energy moving op codes and this one
takes a little bit more digging because
the answer is actual severally several
layers down in the call stack underneath
some templates and macros and some
random craft but eventually you get at
this thing called right barrier field
now the word barrier is a little
overloaded in computer science here it
means something that the runtime has to
do before writing to a reference field
there's also the concept of a read
barrier but it's really not that
important to this particular discussion
anyway
take a look at what write barrier field
does it calls mark card see I told you
there'd be cards all right in this case
a card is just an area of memory it's
kind of like a page only it's not the
same size and besides that word was
taken so we call it a card now marking
the card just says hey something in this
memory has changed now why do we even
have cards and it's really for the same
reason we have pages so we can have
metadata about memory that takes up less
room than the memory we're describing so
for pages we keep you know data like
whether it's read-only or executable or
any of that other and protect stuff for
cards it's pretty much just dirty or
clean it's just a right if you look at
the source code it's not even an atomic
which by the way we can get away with
because there's no read-modify-write
in a concurrent environment it's just a
right and the Reed has done use during
the GC pause where the value can't
change
so what's so important about the
card-table even given the information in
the karge the GC doesn't have to rescan
every single object during the pause it
can focus its attention on the objects
that might be dirty and this idea
extends far beyond just finding the
objects a change in the last concurrent
scan by the way there are plenty of
objects that almost never changed for
existence for instance class objects if
we can we want to avoid scanning those
objects ever and we can get away with
that because if for some reason those
objects ever do change their cards will
be marked now the card ID isn't perfect
for instance if a card happens to
contain more than one object there's no
way to tell which object is dirty all of
them have to be rescanned even where
it's an array of objects count as one
object when it comes to card marking
that's one object with a whole lot of
references which means if you insert or
remove an object from an array the
entire array gets rescanned so now we
come full circle because our pool of
card rectangles might actually end up as
a victim of card marking I know there's
a country song in there somewhere but
it's only one of several factors that
make allocations cheaper on art and I
wish I had actually more slides to talk
through the rest of them but I'll talk
to a talk about a few of them one of
them is better collection past
scheduling no art in general tends to do
a better job of figuring out when to run
collection passes which means that GC
for alloc is a thing of the past
and too it keeps a list of objects that
have been allocated since the last GC so
when you add that information to the
card table art gets the ability to
collect super short-lived objects
without even triggering a GC pause and
that's why allocating ludicrous numbers
of simple object doesn't kill art the
way did dalvik and - oh sorry that's
this is I already said this so finally
let me let me in conclusion because
we're cuz it's gonna be really short
guys so don't walk out of here and tell
your friends the allocations don't
matter anymore first of all we don't
want to incur the wrath of colt and
besides the point of this talk isn't
necessarily just to add to your stock of
pro tips but hopefully it's to give you
a little bit of understanding of how
things are working inside of android and
how you can - and enjoy going through
Android yourself so I hope I've given
you
some of the tools and encouragement you
need to go on your own adventures to the
Android code base I mean after all what
else is open source for if we can't
learn from it so we're looking forward
to hearing your stories if you want to
contact me that's where I can be found
and thank you all and you all get 20
minutes back or so so I enjoy the rest
of your time here at the barbecue and if
any questions you can I'm more more than
happy to take them now